greetings exalted ones I'm mark Ehlert
Jedi Knight and friend of Captain solo
you may think that I'm a fancy-dress lad
from Canada but I consider myself from
Tatooine why cuz I'm a huge Star Wars
fan and we're about to boldly go where
that's not the not wrong franchise
today's show is an epic contest set in a
galaxy far far away
where I'm gonna pitch Star Wars trilogy
against each other I know I know you get
nervous around competition but the
franchise is called Star Wars we're
gonna have a war for supremacy but don't
worry no one's gonna die unless you're a
boffin am i right it's the Star Wars
prequel trilogy versus a Star Wars
sequel trilogy episodes 1 through 3
directed by George Lucas against episode
7 through 9
directed by guys not named to George
Lucas I have a bad feeling about this
I'm just presuming we all know the
classic trilogy is the best and at the
best movie in that franchise is I heard
Return of the Jedi and you are right the
original three films are untouchable
they're perfect in every way and it's
impossible to improve them unless your
name is McClung key I love you
I know here's how the battle will be
waged
round one box office round 2 tomato
meter round 3 character
ad then we'll do a wildcard round which
trilogy of the most Ewok No you know Oh
Oh
figure out something else I know you're
excited I'm nervous I'm taking us right
into an asteroid field don't bother
telling me the eyes am I really about to
compare Star Wars trilogies on the
internet Mesa has a bad feeling about
this
but as an old dead wizard once told me
the force will be with you always
that's not how the force works round one
bots on in breaking news these movies
tend to do very well at the box office
their all-time blockbusters and we were
reminded just how big of a force they
are in both 1999 and 2015 when we once
again embarked on a new trilogy in the
Star Wars galaxy the prequels had so
much hype built around them for years
would they ever happen then in 1997 the
original trilogy was re-released in
theaters with some new scenes effects
and music and the few new surprises
say what you want about them now but at
the time it was exciting because George
was tinkering with new toys like an old
prizefighter back in the gym getting the
rust off he's not Jewish Lucas
Thanksgiving 1998 we were treated to my
favorite trailer of all time to this day
the teaser for Star Wars Episode one The
Phantom Menace from there anticipation
was building to a fever pitch until
audiences finally got to witness the
film the following May and wow did they
show up in droves it was the very first
film to cross the hundred million dollar
in an opening weekend domestic mark and
it went on to gross 1.2 billion dollars
worldwide following that up was Attack
of the Clones earning 900 million
dollars worldwide and then Revenge of
the Sith at 1 billion dollars even talk
about having the high ground it's over
Anakin and since we're talking about
coin it's worth noting that Star Wars
merch had sold an excess of 4.5 billion
dollars from 1977 to 1999 I still have
the Darth Maul Mountain Duke
at home to prove my allegiance to the
cause do I do you all want to know how
much Star Wars Myrcella at least twenty
five billion dollars in sales what does
that even look like that's enough money
to drown Scrooge McDuck
and it's been boosting significantly
banks to the sequel trilogy Disney
bought the rights to Lucasfilm in 2012
and once again the hype machine was
primed in time for the December 2015
release of episode 7 the force awakens
our old favorites were coming back and
there was a new droid soccer ball to get
jazzed about finding a new opening
weekend standard was set to the tune of
two hundred and forty seven million
dollars domestically and the movie went
on to gross two point 1 billion dollars
across the globe which is still like 700
million dollars short of avatar look I
like that movie but what was going on in
2009 was Christmas that bad did we hate
hanging out with our families that much
that year Wow the last Jedi was the 8th
episode in the saga and grossed 1.5
billion dollars worldwide and this past
holiday season the rise of Skywalker was
released and has since crossed the
billion dollar barrier so if you keeping
score at home the sequels are winning
4.4 billion dollars to 3.7 billion
dollars but here's why I'm giving the
nod to the prequels because I do wait in
line for two days to get tickets yeah
the AMC 24 in Hampton Virginia
I had to camp out overnight and I even
went there to go see The Mummy three
weeks beforehand to scout the location I
was ready
and you had to be back at the turn of
the millennium you know how I got
tickets to the sequel trilogy hmm there
was no such Magic Device in 1999 you
waited in line he got into the theater
10:30 p.m. for the midnight show it was
an all day and all night affair movie
theaters weren't as sophisticated they
couldn't handle crowds as well as they
do nowadays and simply didn't have as
many show times so yeah the sequel
trilogy made more money than the
prequels but the prequels worked harder
to earn our allowance I'm also giving
the prequels points for having the third
film where the Sith get revenge that
made more money than the second film
where the clones attack in the new
trilogy each subsequent movie made less
bucks overall so the prequels get the
point
midi-chlorian count is off the chart
[Music]
round two
tomato meter thus far we proved in the
Star Wars movies made lots of money and
that I love denim but how did these
silly space fantasy westerns for kids
fare on the tomato meter a look we shall
take the sequel trilogy opens strong
with an impressive 93% for the force
awakens followed up by 91% for the last
Jedi by comparison the Phantom Menace
currently sits in a rotten 53 percent an
attack of the clones is barely fresh at
65%
however revenge of the sith helped the
prequels out tremendously with a
volcanic rock solid 80% that gives the
three prequel films of fresh average of
66 percent meanwhile episode 9 the rise
of skywalker only mustered 52% on the
tomato meter
that's the lowest Star Wars live-action
film ever that costs the sequel trilogy
it's a average and now it'll never get
into Princeton I didn't go to Princeton
but I did attend Wake Forest University
known as the Harvard of the Appalachian
Mountains and thus I was able to
decipher that the sequel average tomato
meters score is 79% and then like I said
the prequels for 66% which is awesome
because 66 as in the line Commander Cody
execute order 66 execute order 66
can you imagine given that order to a
guy named Cody Cody is the summer
lifeguard at a pool not the person
responsible for initiating a religious
genocide anyway the sequels snagged the
win in this round and we're tied at one
apiece
I'll be charged I'm in charge now phasma
look it's Star Wars so nostalgia alone
is gonna get most of us to buy a ticket
the music the crawl text the sound
effects we love it but which trilogy
gave us more new characters to add into
the Canon who are we gonna be nostalgic
for when they make the next series of
movies
Phantom Menace naturally had many of the
classic trilogy characters although they
were much younger if you're a youth you
gotta have someone to train you so for
obi-wan that was quite on Jen
be mindful of the Living force young
padawan if you're a Jedi you need a
civilization to protect and that was led
by Queen Amidala on the dark side of the
force we were introduced to Darth Maul
the sinister apprentice to sheave
I know Palpatine isn't a new character
but it is cool to see him faking the
good guy for a while we also met the
Jedi Council which featured mace windu
we met Anakin's mom Shmi really I was
her name Shmi this is my daughter
Shmi Sebulba a bunch of kids and okay
yes fine Jar Jar Binks hey the kids
loved Jar Jar all right we all have our
thoughts I have my opinion the kids
loved him and Watteau apparently wears a
diaper it's a mix of good and bad in
that flick but we were also introduced
to the never not awesome dual sided
lightsaber look at how cool one side
looks lit up and you're like and then
are you kidding me the other side it's
just so awesome in terms of characters
the force awakens had an easier time and
it's up for task at the same time we got
to see the big three of HA and Luke and
Leia again although never together
that's easy we're gonna love all of them
but the challenge was introducing us to
a new cast they would actually care
about and it succeeded the best big
three since Duncan Ginobili and Parker
was Finn Rey and Poe we're gonna do this
yeah throughout the sequel trilogy they
had great chemistry so great in fact
that at some point we had theories about
who was gonna hook up with whom if you
guys want to come over to my place to
read my fanfiction shoot me a DM the
prequels would go on to give his
characters like Jango Fett who was cool
but I didn't really love how his kid
fits into the whole world and Count
Dooku played by the always imposing
Christopher Lee the sequels gave us Rose
Tico who represented hope in the galaxy
bb-8 who represented heart and toughness
and Maz Kanata who is kind of like all
the girls and girls wrapped up in one
tiny alien
no oh and kylo Ren you're never gonna
guess who his daddy is he's under the
influence of Snoke when we meet him and
he's trying to be a leader but Hux ain't
having it
so before I render my verdict in this
round let's take a quick look at these
trilogies and where the characters ended
up who we already knew the prequels turn
anakin from a little kid who's very good
at pod racing and building droids into
Darth Vader and they gave obi-wan a
veteran's outlook on life with some
giant regrets the sequels I'm gonna
prepare you they didn't end well for
most of our old pals but not before we
got to see Harrison Ford embody Han Solo
one more time some compelling
introspection from Luke and a hopeful
matriculation of force usage and
leadership from Leia so if I'm grading
on characters as much as I love the
direction the sequels took how can I
vote for a trilogy that killed off my
three favorite heroes of all time thank
goodness it didn't kill Chewie they
tease us with it just not cool but in
fairness they also gave us new people we
genuinely care about Plus Captain phasma
and the prequels although we got some
new favorites it's hard for me to look
at Darth Vader and not think no it helps
further sequels cause at the acting in
chemistry at those films it's just a lot
better be honest would you rather hang
out with Finn Rey and Poe or Padme and
Anakin Babu Frick puts it over the edge
for me and the sequels win round number
three bear up two two one open hello me
a foot bubble book
wild card round most iconic moments kids
life is all about moments and since Star
Wars is life there's been some pretty
memorable stuff and while I have finally
come around to the idea that maybe the
prequels aren't the most well made films
ever or well acted Gilly I will always
defend the hill that each one has at
least one moment that's worth loving it
usually involves the good old laser
swords Darth Maul getting double team to
the N phantom menace by qui-gon and
obi-wan or remember when we saw Yoda and
he turned on the lightsaber the end of
Attack of the Clones
that was awesome and then the lightsaber
fight we've been promised since we were
little kids I will do what I must
you will try obi-wan Anakin that leads
to him becoming Darth Vader at the
climax of Revenge of the Sith and that
was just as epic as I'd always hoped and
you just fast-forward through the part
where Padme dies of a broken heart with
JJ Abrams or Rian Johnson at the Helms
for the sequels you knew you're gonna be
getting some quality filmmaking and
moments like reloj teaming up in snoke's
throne room in the last Jedi certainly
speak to that kylo and Rey battled again
in the rise of Skywalker where the
second Death Star as the setting it was
pouring rain but they ain't golfers the
more rain the more cinematic those force
jumps become but it does occur to me
that the most memorable moments in the
sequel trilogy are the ones that play on
our nostalgia Chile
[Music]
the chewy were home seen seeing Luke's
x-wing flying a battle one last time
Leia embracing Han once more the most
original notable moments to me and the
sequels was Luke going out like a
meditative boss it was an Old West
showdown done through the lens of a hot
yoga studio and I ate it up but if the
bulk of the sequel moments are reminding
us why we fell for the classic trilogy
in the first place the prequels are full
of instances that foreshadow what we
already know is coming whether it's Boba
Fett holding his old man's helmet or
Palpatine waxing too young Anakin about
the tragedy of Darth Plagueis those
films rewarded us folks who had watched
the classic trilogy over and over again
the prequels also helped establish
characters and timelines we see later in
Clone Wars and the rebels animated
series and the young sequels have
already spawned a number of novels and
comics that help fill in the gaps
between the fall of the Empire and the
rise of the first order but after all
this evidence it supports both sides I
rely on my beer infused gut to render
the final verdict it's the pre tools
yeah
from Darth Maul pacing back and forth
daring obi-wan to flinch all the way the
Darth Vader and Palpatine looking over
the galaxy they're about to dominate the
prequels do it for me they're not great
films but the moments of excitement they
continue to provide more than make up
for that
[Music]
so we're tied at two and now my job gets
tough I gotta pick a winner between the
movies I can't doubt overnight to see
and the movies that I never thought
could possibly exist this is such an
emotionally exhausted decision if I get
through this I should become a Jedi
Knight half-witted scruffy-looking
nerf-herder anyway before I make the
call let's admit that either one of
these endeavors panned out exactly like
we had hope yes I said it
both trilogies have flaws for the
prequels what if there had been someone
to check George Lucas's vision to govern
which effects you're gonna blow us away
and which scenes might actually be
better served on an actual location
sometimes creativity flows out of
limitations better than it does of the
galaxies at your fingertips it's easy to
Monday Morning Quarterback it now but
would any of us have had the gussto
necessary to tell George
Anakin didn't build c-3po and for the
sequels what if there had been one
cohesive filmmaking vision responsible
for all three films would viewers feel
like the sequel trilogy connected better
would there have been such a rift
between fans after the second one what
do we get Palpatine back at all in the
game of prequels versus sequels I'll
take the new one I find them more
rewatchable more emotional and a little
less cringy you may feel different and
that's okay to be honest their fan
fiction and the prequels came from the
actual creator themselves but as of now
this thing belongs to all of us and so
now it's your chance to voice your
opinion vote for the trilogy that you
love the most in the comments below
and if you feel like giving us reasons
have that it's been a rough road being a
Star Wars fan recently as spoiled as we
are with all the new movies novels and
baby Yoda it's also frustrating when you
constantly feel outnumbered against that
unforgiving swamp known as the Internet
so be respectful be honest and let's
teach the rest of this wretched hive of
scum and villainy how to enjoy the thing
we all love thanks for watching I'm Mark
Ellis and I hate sand it's rough force
everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]